If the world was ending, and you could save only
one hundred and sixteen images as the final record
of planet Earth, what kind of moments would
you preserve? This is an actual question NASA
faced in 1977, when they decided to attach to the
Voyager spacecrafts golden records encoded with a
selection of photos intended to immortalize
life on our fragile planet. And when I look
at these pictures, which have now left our solar
system and are hurtling out into the cosmic dark,
I can’t get out of my head how they will
probably, one day, be all that’s left of us. In
the vacuum of space, these images could last
for billions of years, outliving the earth,
outliving the sun. And though that should
maybe be comforting… I think it scares me.
(Title: Why Deep Space Scares Us)
(Space Chatter)
Space has long been a birthplace of existential
dread. Early astronaut programs were haunted
by concerns of “Space Madness,” the theory that
humans would be mentally and spiritually broken
by entering the celestial abyss. It makes sense.
Space is a deathtrap. Without a spacesuit the
very blood in your veins would form bubbles
that block circulation, the neurons in your
brain exploding with pain until lack of oxygen
causes you to pass out — with death arriving just
ninety seconds later. Even a successful voyage
involves a prolonged period in cramped seclusion
surrounded by the hostile dark. Though “Space
Madness” is no longer an official term, anxiety,
mood swings, and severe emotional distress have
all been documented in those who have touched
the void. The idea that a human mind plunged
into the infinite sea of space might, you know,
drown, has crept into the foundations of how
we depict the cosmos. In 2001: A Space Odyssey,
the narrative begins in the shallows — depicting
a clean, orderly future of space travel, one that
would have been comforting to its late 60’s
audience. Yet in both the film and the novel,
these early space scenes are a façade, a veneer
of fathomability concealing the gaping maw of
the unfathomable. The deeper you descend into
the story, the clearer it becomes that all the
artificial gravity and neatly divided meals amount
to a futile attempt to give order to a chaotic
universe. Like space itself, 2001 ultimately
proves immense and impenetrable, feeling
like something the mind wasn’t meant to fully
encompass. A counterpoint to this vastness exists
in Andrei Tarkovsky’s film Solaris. The story of
a psychologist sent to a research station where
all crewmembers have become trapped within their
own memories, Solaris is technically another tale
of space-born madness. Yet while 2001 spans from
the dawn of humanity to a nebulous future stage
of evolution, the scale of Solaris is intensely
personal. Despite primarily taking place in space,
the film, like the characters, constantly flashes
back to small, intimate moments on Earth. Far from
a story of humanity’s ascension, Solaris makes the
case that the maddening power of space has less to
do with the stars, and more to do with trauma
we carry with us into the dark. Like preserved
photographs, the past lingers — both a steadying
anchor and crushing weight. (Character Gasps) In
the face of a vast, indifferent universe, how
do we decide what moments to hold onto? The game
Outer Wilds forces you to confront this question
— over, and over, and over again. You play as an
alien exploring the cosmos in a worryingly
low-tech spaceship, and the main thing you
do in Outer Wilds is, well, die. The game is a
crash course in why space is so nightmarish. But
every failure is an opportunity to learn from your
mistakes, because — spoiler alert for the first
twenty-two minutes of the game: every time you
perish, you’re sent backwards to the start of a
time loop. It’s a mechanic that changes the value
of each moment. Though I remained cautious for my
first few loops, I soon began to throw myself into
the void without care, all my fears of space blown
away. Simultaneously, I began to skip over smaller
moments. Why waste time roasting a marshmallow or
speaking with a friend if all this is going to
be reset anyways? …Yet at the end of each life,
Outer Wilds displays images depicting all you
accomplished, your very own Golden Record. It’s
a feature that subtly reframes what experiences
are significant. Watching the sunrise might not
get you closer to beating the game, but when
your life literally flashes before your eyes…
it’s the moment that stands out. Yet there’s this…
other moment that stands out. Late into the game,
I became separated from my ship. I wasn’t too
nervous, at first. I knew I could definitely catch
up with — oh wow, that’s really moving. Caught in
the gravity of a planet, my ship faded further and
further out of view. Soon, it was hopeless… and as
I looked out across oblivion, I realized this loop
wasn’t going to end until I ran out of oxygen. And
though I knew I’d wake up back where I’d started,
the thought of drifting until then, waiting for my
inevitable demise, made me feel… Well, it reminded
me of a historical fragment I’d learned long ago.
The first living thing to orbit the Earth was a
dog named Laika. Part of a Soviet experiment to
discover the harmful effects of space on a body,
Laika’s journey through the stars was designed to
be strictly one way, sent to space onboard a tiny,
metal coffin. It was assumed she’d die in
space from running out of oxygen — instead,
the craft overheated. The last words she likely
ever heard was a biologist saying 'please forgive
us.’ …My ill-fated drift through the cosmos didn’t
end when I ran out of oxygen either. Instead,
my body slowly fell into the sun, the voyage
concluding in premature flames. Of course,
unlike Laika, my journey then continued —
although the unsettling experience stayed
with me. …Onboard her doomed craft, Laika’s
heartrate accelerated to three times its
usual rate. She was terrified. Did she also feel
betrayed, I wonder? Did she understand enough of
what was happening to feel betrayed? There’s
a photo of a dog on the golden record, meant
to commemorate the loyalty of our canine friends…
'Please forgive us,’ Laika. Should she forgive us?
‘The trajectory of this ship is unchanging.’
In Douglas Trumbull’s Silent Running, a vessel
is on an unalterable path towards annihilation.
In Claire Denis’s High Life, a vessel is on an
unalterable path towards annihilation. In Cecile
Richard’s Under a Star Called Sun, a vessel is
on a… you get it. As a piece of interactive
fiction, Under a Star Called Sun stands out
from the two films, telling through pixel art
and short snippets of text the story of a lone
cosmonaut whose ship is drifting into the sun.
Yet despite their hopeless status, the explorer
continues to care for the plants aboard their
condemned vessel. It’s a ritual the protagonists
of all three pieces of media take part in for
different reasons. In Silent Running, the plants
are the last specimens of vegetation from a barren
Earth, a final record of green. In High Life,
the plants are the sole source of food for the
main character and his infant child, a matter of
survival. Yet none of these characters is going
to survive for very long — though they continue
to obsess over their plants’ health, maintaining
their routines even knowing the end is coming. ‘I
check on the plants in the greenhouse. I check
for bugs. I check the moisture of the soil. I
check the dust on the leaves. And when no one is
around, I hum to them.’ Like the crew in Solaris,
the astronaut in A Star Called Sun is trapped
in their memories, the ship’s interior sometimes
distorting into a street corner from their past.
Memories invade the film High Life with similar
abruptness — vignettes from the main character’s
childhood coming and going without context. It
seems reflective of how the protagonist’s child
only knows Earth from fragmented images on the
ship’s corrupted hard drive. Instead of a sun,
the ship in High Life headed towards a black hole.
And yet the main character continues to raise his
child, to give her whatever life he can, no matter
how short. Despite the looming cosmic destruction,
the film argues these moments matter, these
memories hold weight. ‘I wish I had made more of
an effort to remember,’ the protagonist says at
the end of A Star Called Sun. ‘I wish I had taken
more photos.’ In addition to images, encoded on
the Golden Record is the Javanese romantic melody
"Puspawarna" — translating to "kinds of flowers."
I think there’s something inspiring about this
song traveling on, in defiance of the cosmos,
billions of kilometers from the nearest flower.
There’s also something profoundly unsettling about
it. Because on an interstellar scale, Voyager
1 has gotten nowhere. Even the closest star is
trillions of miles further away. Space is so
much emptier than we realize. When we think
of the planets, our mind goes to the model from
classrooms that has them all in a neat row. But
space doesn’t look like this. It doesn’t even look
like this — that’s still way too close together.
It looks like this. That tiny, pale blue dot
beneath Saturn’s rings? That’s the Earth.
And everything in space is constantly moving,
hurtling through the dark at breakneck speeds.
We like to think of that darkness as something
loud, something that ships can audibly woosh
through. But without air molecules to vibrate, the
vacuum of space is silent. There are no explosions
either — at least not the fiery type from sci-fi
movies. A real space battle would be dead quiet,
punctuated only with the occasional burst of
heat that would quickly implode. How is anyone
supposed to navigate this vast, silent, alien sea?
In our ongoing search for extraterrestrial life,
we’ve turned to radio waves to make noise in the
cosmos. Some of these signals have traveled as
far out as three hundred trillion kilometers.
Want to see that on a map? Here it is! Sorry,
I’ll zoom in. Maybe once more. There, that’s
the area our messages have reached. It’s another
pale blue dot. And it’s probably an exaggeration,
because most of our signals, which are primarily
a jumble of old tv and radio dramas, likely fall
apart after that many light years, the memories
blurring into meaningless static. In the game The
Anglerfish Project, it is your job to sort through
this static. You play as an old man working for
a mysterious company in the far reaches of space,
using a probe attached to an actual fishing
pole to catch and document wayward signals
from Earth. Most are a jumble of nonsense — old
advertisements and PSAs. But sometimes you’ll reel
in a love letter, or a fragment of history. It’s
a lonely, isolating experience that encourages you
to reflect on the types of messages we’ve blasted
into the void. It made me wonder what an alien
intelligence would even make of our detritus.
Beyond being time capsules, the Golden Records
are also designed to be messages informing
aliens of our planet. After all, the voyager
probes won’t dissipate like radio waves — though
they’re much slower. If by some miracle an alien
found and decoded the record, they’d discover
along with images and music, sounds of the Earth,
including chimpanzee noises (screeches). I’m not…
entirely sure an alien would understand the intent
behind that one. I’m not entirely sure I do. But
what if, right? What if these records did make
contact, what if extraterrestrials understood
their contents, and traced the craft back to
Earth? The scariest moment of the Outer Wilds
probably wasn’t that time I fell into the sun,
but when I descended into a fog in the center
of a planet and saw… are those stars? They were
in fact, the lights of giant alien anglerfish.
And unfortunately, they noticed me. …Maybe we
don’t want aliens to hear us. The ‘Dark Forest
Hypothesis’ is the theory that the reason space
seems so devoid of life is because any species
that makes too much noise is extinguished by
hostile extraterrestrial life. Science fiction has
long told stories of humans alerting something to
our presence we should have left alone. In some
horror fiction, these aliens roll up to our home
planet, bringing the destruction directly to
us. But I think the scarier incarnation of
horror-alien is one encountered in the far reaches
of space. The aliens in these stories often feel
like personifications of the unknown itself, a
punishment for our blind, hubristic push into
the beyond. It’s not just the aliens that make
the edge-of-space-horror genre frightening… It’s
the isolation. Okay, having said that, we now
obviously have to talk about the game Alien:
Isolation. Based on the iconic film franchise,
this game has you explore an empty ship — empty,
except for, of course, the alien. There’s a
litany of techniques the game uses to make
this creature scary. There’s the fact your weapons
barely work, the fact it can move through vents,
the fact that your only way of tracking it is
with this tiny analogue screen that forces you to
glance away from what’s in front of you. But the
most effective technique of all has nothing to do
with the creature, and everything to do with the
setting. An effective horror-genre space station…
is basically a haunted house. Though lacking in
cobwebs and creaking floors, it is a place of dim
corridors concealing monsters, one that sequesters
its characters from any hope of rescue. The cosmos
beyond the station can be seen as part of the
structure, with space itself a single enormous
horror-set-piece — a setting so frightening, you
almost don’t need the alien. Is a space filled
with hostile life scarier than a space that’s
empty? Arthur C. Clarke, author of 2001: A Space
Odyssey, famously stated: "Two possibilities
exist: either we are alone in the universe or
we are not. Both are equally terrifying." Here on
Earth, we are perhaps the most sheltered children
of the universe. Solar wind from our sun shields
us from interstellar radiation, creating an island
of safety in the roiling cosmic ocean. Jupiter
defends Earth from asteroids like a protective
older sibling with its gravitational pull. Earth’s
magnetic field extends tens of thousands of
kilometers into space, safeguarding the surface
from deadly charged particles. Mars and Venus
didn’t get magnetospheres at all. It’s difficult
to convey just how inhospitable the other planets
in our solar system are. Jupiter’s Great Red Spot,
that little dot on the planet’s surface — is a
storm larger than the Earth itself. If you were
to descend into this maelstrom, temperatures would
rise to over one thousand three hundred degrees
Celsius — around two thousand four hundred degrees
Fahrenheit. Not even the cracked, yellowing
surface of Venus, otherwise the hottest planet
in our solar system, gets that scorching.
On the opposite end of the spectrum,
the outer Ice Giants, Uranus and Neptune, spin so
far from the warmth of the sun, their atmospheres
regularly fall hundreds of degrees below freezing.
Beyond our solar system, there are likely billions
of exoplanets in our galaxy alone — although we’ve
only managed to spot around five-thousand. Given
the sheer number of potential Earth-like worlds,
it seems that there has to be some other form
of life out there. But maybe that’s a privileged
Earthling perspective. It seems like other beings
must exist because, well, we exist. But until
we know more about the origin of life, it’s
challenging to calculate just how lucky we are to
be here. Because we’ve had it so relatively easy,
space hasn’t always been a source of fear.
In the past, some cultures assumed it was
a flat backdrop, a shallow dome of tiny lights
surrounding a globe that sits at the center of
the universe. Even as our understanding grew, and
the scale of the solar system became more and more
apparent, many assumed we’d find other habitable
worlds right next door. In the late 19th and
early 20th century, the idea that Mars or the Moon
might be full of undiscovered life didn’t seem so
far-fetched. When your only frame of reference
is the lushness of Earth, space seems like it
would be jam-packed with extraterrestrials. Though
once a distant dream, space travel, too, was once
portrayed more flippantly. In Jules Verne’s 19th
century novel from Earth to the Moon, the lead
characters make it to the moon by shooting their
vessel out of a giant cannon, because… why not?
It’s difficult to imagine the true nature
of space. A place where, without gravity,
your bones rapidly lose density. A place where the
lack of days and nights create insomnia. A place
of silent, inhospitable lifelessness. Perhaps the
closest thing to true “Space Madness” manifested
during the 1976 Soviet mission Soyuz 21. The
operation was supposed to be routine — involving
a sixty day stay onboard the Salyut 5 space
station. But just a few weeks in, the crew
claimed a maddening odor had filled the cabin, a
smell so toxic and persistent the operation had
to be called off. Yet allegedly, upon the reserve
crew’s arrival, no unusual smell or fume leakage
was detected. The scent was likely an intense
delusion, a nightmare born from claustrophobic
conditions mixed with the psychological terror
of the cosmic vastness. …Perhaps, it’s better
to remain on the ground. But even in Earth’s
protective embrace, we are not completely safe
from the cosmos. Asteroids hurled from the beyond
aren’t just the stuff of disaster movies. Space
rocks large enough to trigger mass extinctions
have stuck our planet in the past, wiping out
far greater dynasties of life than humanity. Even
with Jupiter looking out for us, the Earth has
close calls all the time. And even if we aren’t on
a collision course with an apocalyptic asteroid,
we are on a collision course with the sun. A few
billion years from now, our star will become a red
giant, and in all likelihood swallow the Earth.
And even if we don’t end in fire, the sun, like
all stars in the universe, is eventually going
to die. In 1816, many people became terrified
that the sun’s death was imminent. Telescopes
discovered massive sunspots growing like mold
upon the solar surface, and temperatures began to
drop. This event, called The Year Without Summer,
saw then-unprecedented snowfall in the Northern
Hemisphere. In the resulting chaos, the somewhat
infamous Lord Byron was inspired to craft an
apocalyptic eulogy simply titled ‘Darkness.’
“I had a dream, which was not all a dream. / The
bright sun was extinguish’d, and the stars / Did
wander darkling in the eternal space, / Rayless,
and pathless, and the icy earth / Swung blind and
blackening in the moonless air.” Of course, the
sun did not go out in 1816. The sunspots actually
had nothing to do with the falling temperatures
—the winter’s true origin was the eruption of the
Mount Tambora stratovolcano in the Pacific, which
blanketed the globe in volcanic gas. Though this
shroud eventually lifted, I see it as a reminder
of how fragile Earth’s atmosphere is, of how
little change it would take to make our planet
just another barren rock. Perhaps impermanence
is the true most frightening aspect of the cosmos.
Even our galaxy won’t endure forever. In roughly
four-point-five billion years, the Milky Way will
collide with the Andromeda galaxy, the galactic
fender-bender flinging untold stars out into the
void. It makes you wonder what the point is. If
nothing lasts, if everything in the universe
is on an unchangeable arc towards annihilation,
why try to preserve anything at all? What meaning
could a single image, a memory, a life — possibly
have? Maybe permeance isn’t what gives something
value. Yes, every plant is going to wilt, every
radio signal is going to decay, every marshmallow
is going to burn or be digested. On a cosmic
scale, the Golden Record probably isn’t going
to get very far. So what? On a personal level,
things that have been lost still matter, moments
still linger, the night sky can still move us,
even with the knowledge that one day every light
will go out. ‘The trajectory of this ship is
unchanging.’ I’m still going to water the plants.
And hey, as always, thank you for watching. If you
enjoyed this video and want to support the
channel, consider liking, subscribing, and
hitting the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious. See you in the next video.